222 5
euh euh euh euh euh
[musique]
5 pouah pouah
Je suis dans ce métier depuis 40 ans.
Cela fait une semaine et j'ai appris que tout cela était sorti, mais la porte était cassée.
Cela sort beaucoup plus et les deux humour sortent trop dans l'épisode 1
Et maintenant je vais venir avec beaucoup d'argent et mangeons comme ça.
[musique]
eww
Non
Pouah
eww
[musique]
pouah pouah
C'est une ressource qui pourrait être délicieuse, mais maintenant c'est si bon marché, si facile à préparer, si facile.
Puisqu'il est jeté, qu'est-ce qui sortira de la conscience que c'est une nécessité quotidienne ?
[musique]
J'ai récupéré de petites flûtes qui étaient sur le point d'être jetées et j'ai refait des choses, alors
Un peu pratique pour ne pas naître
En pensant à quelque chose qui pourrait être utilisé de manière semi-permanente, une cravate 2tv est sortie.
C'est bon
[musique]
eww
Oh oh oh
[musique]
sur
pouah pouah
5 Le plus important est de réduire le nombre de n lignes utilisées, et le second est
Inutilisé et utilisé plusieurs fois
C'est le troisième ou euh site Nous sommes un quartier en plastique moitié-moitié eph.
je ne propose pas de solution
[musique]
huer
euh ou
eww
[musique]
Ah tera
d'accord